i also find it really scary,
as even the
Head of the Catholic Church here the word
is turned around in the mouth,
to defame him as a Putin troll uh,
the state
the akapst has very clearly not appealed,
that Ukraine
should surrender or that it should capitulate,
but he has said literally,
Negotiations are never a surrender.
they are the courage of the land,
not to drive the country to suicide.
and I believe that this appeal of the Pope uh,
more urgent than ever.
very many countries,
the south have also been demanding this for some time.
Turkey now also has another
Initiative launched,
to enable peace talks on their ground.
we see,
that the front is rather at the expense of Ukraine
shifts.
nevertheless From Kiev comes to all these initiatives
always only rejection.
of course no one knows,
how willing to negotiate or also how willing to compromise
the Russian leadership would be at the end,
if there were negotiations.
but it is already remarkable,
that at least From the kremmel
such initiatives are not rejected,
while from Kiev they are very massive
be rejected immediately.
there is still 1 decree in Ukraine,
explicitly prohibits negotiations with Russia.
but the question is how will this war ever end,
if not through negotiation?
and that through the many gamechangers,
that we allegedly delivered,
Battle Tanks,
Fighter Jets,
theVerhandlungsposition of Ukraine
has not even improved,
but rather worsened,
we have a lot of that last year,
seen very clearly.
in,
to that extent it is 1 major concern for us.
that is why this week we will be in the Bundestag
submit a request to that effect,
that the federal government
gets behind the Pope's initiative,
that the federal government has finally also
initiatives and such peace talks
tries to make it possible.
that means,
of course,
that we,
I have to say very clearly and we think uh,
that it can't be,
that we unconditionally support Ukraine,
if they have all theverhandlungsangebote
or refuses to allow them to negotiate.
this war must be ended
and this will be without negotiations
will not be possible.